over a century has passed since
corrupted wizard akka Kessel was
thwarted by the Allied forces of I
Swindell the source of castles power
that crystal shard was destroyed but not
before leaving a permanent mark on
Icewind Dale the region surrounding ice
and snow transformed into a mysterious
substance that came to be known as black
ice the hammer stone dwarves learned to
forge the black ice into powerful magic
infused armor and weapons however it
soon became clear that the substance was
marked by a violent curse over time
several groups have taken up residence
in Iceland a beach with his own agenda
the arcane brotherhood claims to have
unlocked the secret to removing the evil
taint from black ice meanwhile the
residents other ten towns believe the
black ice is death by right with a
rumored return of a [ __ ] castle and his
dark forces the conflict in Icewind Dale
will soon reach its breaking point which
side will you fight for will you uncover
the truth behind the resurrection of